only Tesla could one-up its own hype and
do it in style there's only one thing
that's beyond ludicrous which is plaid
that's an event in Los Angeles that was
supposedly all about launching an
electric semi-truck a crazy enough
sounding proposition in itself Elon Musk
came back to the stage at the very end
to reveal a new roadster a low sleek
sports car with a removable top a 200
kilowatt hour battery which is twice as
large as any car Tesla currently sells
and a 600 mile range the original
roadster is how Tesla started so in a
way when this thing goes on sale
apparently in 2020 this will be a return
to its roots but it's also a shot across
the bow of the likes of Porsche with its
mission II and the other mainstream
automakers promising electric
performance cars just give a hardcore
smackdown to gasoline cars then let's
rewind this is the Tesla semi truck the
thing that the crowd came to see it's
the latest piece in Elon Musk's plan to
shift the world away from fossil fuel
based transportation
[Music]
musk has spent the last decade working
on sports and passenger cars but trucks
are where he could really make a
difference the EPA says transportation
accounts for 27 percent of America's
greenhouse gas emissions and diesel
engines released dirty particulates
lowering air quality and raising health
risks for local residents true to form
Tesla's ambitions a grand and its
product is impressive the truck is fast
not roadster fast but seriously fast for
a truck or even for a normal car with a
zero to 60 time of just five seconds and
the key statistic the range is 500 miles
at maximum load and at highway speed and
it'll recharge 400 of those miles in
just 30 minutes at a new network of
Piper chargers yep
another new Tesla term hyper charge is
being more powerful than superchargers
and being a Tesla the Semite will come
with autopilot which allows it to
automatically brake and stay in its lane
on the freeway musk didn't say a lot
about full autonomous driving but it is
likely that's his long-term plan and
it's something that a lot of other
companies are trying to master and Tesla
isn't the only one using electricity to
power its 18 wheelers the Nikola one
uses hydrogen to generate electricity
through a fuel cell Toyota is doing the
same both companies think that could
make sense for quicker refueling Siemens
is running trials with trucks that use
overhead cables for power which seems
crazy that actually makes sense on
specific truck heavy routes
these new vehicles went down well with
the invited audience but making one or
two vehicles is easy building them a
scale is hard
[Music]
Tesla's no stranger to manufacturing
slip-ups and missed deadlines the young
automaker is struggling to deliver its
new affordable model three sedan already
and there's no indication of where it'll
build either the truck or the new sports
car Musk's critics will call these new
vehicles a distraction but if Tesla can
pull it off it might just hold all of us
into the future
[Music]